[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Río de
Janeiro con nuestra corresponsal Valeria
sacone porque Brasil permanecía bajo
atención ante el anuncio de nuevas
protestas por parte de Seguidores del
presidente el ex presidente ayer
bolsonaro que al final fueron canceladas
y por ello se adoptaron varias medidas
de seguridad Valeria muy buenas noches
cuéntenos cómo se estaba protegiendo
Brasil
Brasil se ha blindado hoy ante el riesgo
de que se pudiesen repetir los ataques
violentos del pasado domingo grupos
bolsonaristas estaban amenazando con
volver a las calles para ser
manifestaciones de retomada de poder las
había prevista en Brasil y también aquí
en Río de Janeiro y muchas ciudades
importantes del país el juez Alexandre
dimorais de la Corte Suprema decidió
accionar toda la maquinaria jurídica y
decidió prohibir la interrupción de las
carreteras y también la invasión de
edificios públicos las penas eran cárcel
o multas de hasta 100.000 reales
equivalentes a 20 mil dólares finalmente
no hubo manifestaciones aquí en Río
tampoco en Brasilia donde se había
cerrado la plaza de los tres poderes y
mientras tanto se ha decidido mantener
alejado del poder al gobernador del
Distrito Federal donde se encuentra
Brasilia y vanéis Rocha considerado
culpable de haber permitido los
destrozos del pasado domingo
y en otros temas Valeria Brasil vivió
hoy un momento histórico al presenciar
la posición de la primera ministra
indígena del país cuéntenos
hoy han tomado posesión las últimas dos
ministras del gobierno de Lula son
soniara que encabeza el Ministerio de
los pueblos indígenas creado por Lula
precisamente para proteger la amazonia y
los pueblos que le habitan y también la
ministra de igualdad racial aniel y
Franco hermana de la concejala
brutalmente asesinada en 2018 María Eli
Franco ha sido una ceremonia muy emotiva
por varias razones la plaza de los tres
poderes y el palacio del plan alto
estaban completamente blindados había
mucha seguridad precisamente para evitar
nuevos disturbios Lula ha participado
las dos ministras llevaban vestimentas
indígenas y de Tom africano que daban un
toque diferente a los últimos al de los
últimos ejecutivos que eran básicamente
formados por hombres de corbata y se
espera que poco a poco con este último
paso de la composición del gobierno
Brasil vuelva a la normalidad tras los
ataques violentos del pasado domingo